[Música]
el trabajo que está haciendo este chef
tiene una gran ventaja
él está concentrado está produciendo
está apasionado con lo que hace y la
ventaja que tiene es que la
retroalimentación de si lo que está
haciendo es bueno o es malo la va a
recibir inmediatamente en 30 minutos va
a saber si la comida que coste hizo que
cocino es buena o es mala y que se pone
este ejemplo porque estamos hablando de
educación y creo que es válido resaltar
que abajo del educador tiene una
desventaja y es el otro lado de esta
moneda el trabajo del educador muchas
veces ve su resultado 20 o 30 años
después no lo puedo ver inmediatamente
cuando hablamos de que el trabajo de los
educadores el ministerio los colegios
privados los colegios científicos los
colegios técnicos están produciendo el
talento del futuro para ser exitosos en
el siglo 21 cuando nos vamos a dar
cuenta si el trabajo fue bueno o fue
malo cuando estemos allá 20 años después
y parte del tema que yo digo que es
injusto es de que hay pocas
probabilidades de regresarnos si hicimos
un mal trabajo
en el tema de educación que es difícil
decir no me regreso puede ser demasiado
tarde hay oportunidades de mejora
siempre pero puede ser demasiado tarde
para construir la ciudad
pensar que costa rica sea una sociedad
exitosa en el siglo 21
yo en realidad no soy educador yo soy un
empresario de tecnología que me ha
involucrado con la educación por dos
motivaciones la primera es que trabajo
en reclutamiento trato profesionales
todos los días
contratar 200 cenas y miles de personas
sobre todo en el área de tecnología y
participo constantemente de la
conversación de si costa rica está
produciendo los profesionales que
ocupamos el talento que ocupamos que
hace falta tal tipo de habilidades está
el tipo de
y conocimiento experiencia entonces mi
primer interés en la educación nace como
empresario yo todos los días contrato
todos los días entrevistó participo con
instituciones nacionales como si de
procomer ministerio de trabajo cámaras
cámara de industria cámara de comercio
es decir estamos produciendo los
procesos los profesionales que ocupamos
es la primera motivación
la segunda motivación es más personal
y es mi familia son mis hijos estos son
mis hijos y mis sobrinos y sobre todo me
motivo la conversación en el sentido de
que mi hijo menor el más pequeño que
está en el centro que tiene diez años un
día conversando me dice papá qué voy a
hacer yo que voy a estar haciendo yo
cuando tenga tu edad
eso fue impactante por dos cosas una
hicimos los números y era el año 2052
entonces me hizo sentir muy viejo yo me
considero joven y eso me hizo sentir
viejísimo pero por otro lado me hizo
entrar en razón de que cuando mi hijo
tenga mi edad vamos a estar entrando en
la segunda mitad del siglo 21 entonces
todo lo que decimos que el siglo 21 trae
tecnología e innovación cambios no es el
futuro es ya son cosas que están
sucediendo ya y sobre todo detona la
conversación alrededor de decir estos
niños que son mi familia mi hijo pequeño
me dijo el medio les estamos dando la
educación les estamos dando las
habilidades del futuro para que ellos
sean exitosos en la sociedad el siglo 21
y eso lo asocio a una estadística que
dice que es todavía un poco más
alarmante en este sentido la estadística
dice que el 65% de los estudiantes que
están hoy día en el sistema educativo
van a trabajar en carreras que no
existen entonces eso lo hace uno
cuestionar si decir un momentito o sea
esta gente va a trabajar en cosas que no
existen entonces cuál es la guía de la
capacitación cuál es la guía de la
orientación de la educación que les
estamos dando y me puse a investigar qué
son esas carreras que no existen les
pongo algunos ejemplos
vemos macrotendencias de lo que se llama
tecnologías exponenciales y vemos por
ejemplo estos tripuladas
aeronáutica no tripulada va a ver una
carrera que es ser un ingeniero en
aeronáutica no tripulada los famosos
drones esa carrera no existe sino balcón
el supo y pregunta esa carrera existen o
no existen ahí la presentado no se ha
aprobado y como hago para crear las
habilidades para que los niños sean
exitosos en esas carreras si alguien va
a estudiar economía posiblemente sea
economía basada en cripto monedas o en
block change entonces cómo hago para
dedicarle tiempo y generar habilidades
alrededor de que el entendimiento de que
es cripto moneda y que es block chains y
ese la economía el futuro si alguien va
a ser arquitectura posiblemente haya un
énfasis en urbanismo
para planear ciudades de autos autónomos
autos que se manejan solos entonces los
estudios que dicen que el 65% de los
estudiantes que están hoy día en el
sistema van a trabajar en carreras que
no existen es porque están proyectando
estas mega tendencias ese es como la
gran preocupación inmediatamente después
de entender esto empezamos a buscar y
decir ok que si podemos hacer hoy
entonces hablamos del que qué hacer qué
acciones medidas iniciativas propuestas
podemos empezar a ejecutar hoy hay unas
muy obvias muy conocidas como el tema de
stem este mes es ciencia tecnología
ingeniería y matemática en inglés
y stem lo que dice es que no es que las
escuelas y los colegios deben enseñar
ciencia que ya lo hacen tecnología tal
vez ingeniería sino que es la
integración de estas cuatro áreas la
diferencia de stem versus la clase de
ciencia es que este es el desarrollo de
las habilidades integradas y que si
ponemos en todas las escuelas y colegios
la clase de stem posiblemente estemos
orientando a nuestros niños al
desarrollo de las habilidades correctas
para ser exitosos en el siglo 21 ahora
como este en paso a otro problema este
mes es relativamente sencillo decir
vamos a hacer este en este mes se ha
convertido en un club de la tarde
típicamente el resultado de este muchas
veces de robótica robótica educativa hay
muchas iniciativas alrededor de robótica
robótica educativa y eso está excelente
lo que pasa es que se convierte muchas
veces en una actividad extracurricular
se convierte una actividad que hacemos
en un club para el turno de los
estudiantes no para todos los
estudiantes y de hecho es un problema
porque si vamos a ver países exitosos
el tema de robótica por ejemplo como
corea corea lo primero que dice es stem
no es un club no es un taller no es un
seminario una vez por mes una vez por
trimestre es siempre es curricular hay
que meterlo transversal a todo el modelo
educativo
ahora se habla de otras cosas que nos
amarran alrededor del que como las 47 el
siglo 21 las 46 y las han escuchado es
comunicación colaboración pensamiento
creativo y creatividad el pensamiento
crítico y creatividad eso en los 40 del
siglo 21 igual es un área de estudio que
uno puede decir muy bien para ser
ciudadanos exitosos para las carreras
que hoy día no existen voy a tratar de
modificar mi contenido para que tengan
las 46 pensamiento crítico creatividad
comunicación colaboración entonces
respuestas a la pregunta el quehacer
existe no son difíciles de encontrar tal
vez lo que es más difícil de encontrar
es el cómo
porque encontramos casos de corea y
podemos investigar casos de finlandia y
singapur y estados unidos países muy
exitosos en su desarrollo educativo sin
embargo que vive en realidades muy
diferentes y la realidad tiene que ver
con todos ustedes son testigos de eso
desde que capacitación recibo cuánta
infraestructura tengo cuánto presupuesto
tengo visión etcétera entonces aquí en
costa rica hoy cuando pensamos que
podemos hacer nos encontramos de que no
hay respuestas en el como porque el cómo
lo tenemos que iniciar nosotros el cómo
lo tenemos que inventar cómo aterrizamos
esto a nuestra realidad de escuelas
públicas y privadas en costa rica y eso
fue un poco una tarea que nos pusimos a
hacer este porque queríamos eso
queríamos que estén y robótica no fuera
un club
queríamos modificar el currículo para
incluirles 4c pero como lo hacemos nos
encontramos con algo muy lógico y desde
que hay un paradigma y el paradigma es
el paradigma del juego de suma cero que
es el juego de suma cero lo que yo gano
usted lo pierde lo que usted pierde yo
gano
básicamente eso nos hace pensar que si
yo quiero meter un contenido adicional
en un programa educativo toca sacar algo
cuando nos involucramos como escuelas en
este caso le sale un ejemplo de una
escuela donde me invitan a ser miembro
de consejo académico llevo buena escuela
y digo que ahí puede impactar esta
escuela vamos a usarla como modelo y me
encuentro con la realidad de que estamos
en el juego de suma cero metamos
robótica transversal ok que sacó un
estudios sociales matemáticas ciencias
español pero es que no hay que sacar
otra cosa pero es que el horario no me
alcanza el tiempo es el mismo las horas
las lecciones los recreos entonces
empezamos a pensar y cómo podemos romper
ese paradigma y de alguna manera lo
empezamos a hacer el primer ejemplo hay
un módulo entre ese grado que se llama
páginas simples
es la primera vez en la trayectoria
proceso educativo donde el niño se le
explica que es polea palanca cuña que
son elementos básicos de la ingeniería
entonces lo que dice este si nosotros
damos una muy buena lección en tercer
grado de los elementos básicos de la
ingeniería y la mecatrónica ese niño va
a hacer conexiones neuronales que le van
a quedar para el futuro y pueda llegar a
ser un muy exitoso ingeniero entonces lo
que optamos fue por dar stem y las 4 c
del siglo 21 intercaladas en el programa
no una hora adicional la tarde no una
hora más temprano no durante el almuerzo
sino intercalado entonces máquinas
simples se enseñan mediante la
construcción de una grúa entonces hay un
proyecto que es la construcción de una
grúa y se estudia la polea
la palanca la cuña y elementos incluso
de física que los niños absorben muy
bien cuando
reciben en lugar de una instrucción que
es el verdadero cambio lo que recibieron
fue una construcción otro ejemplo es
energías renovables es un gran ejemplo
para costa rica en energías renovables
se estudió en quinto grado y en lugar de
explicar de manera teórica analógica que
la energía solar se construye un
vehículo solar con elementos de robótica
educativa y se hace una competencia del
vehículo solar que camina más rato y más
rápido otro ejemplo es el ejemplo en las
impresoras 3d una de las tecnologías
exponenciales es el concepto de
impresores 3d en lugar de meter una
clase de impresiones 3d como 'club en la
tarde o en la mañana y poner a competir
el currículo normal de la escuela
lo optamos en estudios sociales cuando
se estudia el elemento de los fósiles y
lo que hacemos es imprimir un fósil en
una impresora 3d sin darse cuenta el
niño recibió dos clases al mismo tiempo
se intercalaron clases en lugar de poner
una competición la otra recibió una
clase de programación de impresora 3d se
llevó para la casa un fósil impreso y le
dijo a su mamá
cuando le pegó en la mala pregunta que
si estoy en la escuela él le cuenta que
fue estuvo en la clase de fósiles
presentarse cuentas tuvo una clase de
impresora 3d y el otro ejemplo es el
ejemplo de virtual reality de realidad
virtual real y aumentada esto lo hicimos
en biología y en ciencias los niños
programan la célula humana y la navegan
mediante un visor de realidad virtual y
realidad aumentada entonces estos son
unos ejemplos de cómo de alguna manera
le encontramos una salida del paradigma
de no poner a competir las nuevas
habilidades que debemos buscar la forma
de intercalar al currículum con con el
programa normal sino ponerlo saco crea
a colaborar de manera que podamos
cumplir el objetivo yo estoy seguro que
hay muchos ejemplos así esto no es en
realidad una innovación para esto hay
mucha gente haciendo esto hay
fundaciones públicas fundaciones
privadas escuelas pero realidad nuestro
mensaje de hoy es que buscaremos la
forma hoy más tarde una conversación en
los siguientes días colaborando con el
ministerio de educación de compartir
estas experiencias porque estoy seguro
que si hacemos una librería o una
colección de experiencias similares
nosotros podemos contar estas cinco como
las que estamos viendo nosotros y usted
nos pueden contar muchas más y podemos
enriquecer una colección de experiencias
que nos ayuden a transformar el modelo
educativo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]